question l'homme at il fini d'évoluer
non
il n'y a pas 36 façons de faire pour que
notre espèce n'évolue plus il faudrait
que nous soyons tous absolument
identique
c'est à cette condition est seulement à
cette condition que la dérive génétique
et la sélection qu'elles soient
naturelles sexuelle ou culturelles
n'aurait plus d'effet sur nous par
exemple dans ces conditions si jamais
une nouvelle maladie s'abattait sur nous
la survie de l'humanité se jouerait à
pile ou face
soit ça passe tout le monde serait
immunisée et s'en sortir et inde m
soit ça casse et alors ce serait la
catastrophe
notre espèce disparaît très bien que
notre espèce continue d'évoluer il est
impossible de prévoir quel sera notre
évolution future
en effet l'évolution est dépendante de
beaucoup trop de facteurs aléatoires
pour être prévisible ce qui est sûr
c'est que les idées très répandu selon
lesquelles nous finiront par perdre
notre petit orteil nos dents de sagesse
et que notre cerveau continuera de
grossir sont fausses et oui car les
pressions de sélection qui ont créé ces
tendances évolutif chez nos ancêtres ne
sont plus du tout les mêmes
aujourd'hui par exemple étant donné que
maintenant on nous retire nos dents de
sagesse avant que ces dernières ne
causent du tort
il n'y a pas de raison particulière pour
qu'elles disparaissent à l'avenir notre
révolution est imprévisible